EYE SOMETHING CROOKED AT THE
FBI.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
ON SUNDAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD
HAD ENOUGH.
HE POINTEDLY TWEETED I HEREBY
DEMAND AND WILL DO SO OFFICIALLY
TOMORROW THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE LOOK INTO WHETHER OR NOT
THE FBI, DOJ INFILTRATED OR
SURVEILLED THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES AND IF
ANY SUCH DEMANDS OR REQUESTS
WERE MADE BY PEOPLE WITHIN THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
WELL, TRUMP HAS A GOOD SENSE.
THIS IS NOTHING NEW IN A WAY.
ON MARCH 4TH 2017, MORE THAN A
YEAR AGO, PRESIDENT TRUMP
CONTENDED THAT HIS PHONES WERE
TAPPED JUST PRIOR TO THE
ELECTION AND OF COURSE THEY GET
TRUMP MEDIA IN THE DEEP STATE
ALL DISMISSED IT.
IT WAS ALL A BUNCH OF NONSENSE.
WHILE OF COURSE WE NOW KNOW THAT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SOUGHT
AND SECURED PERMISSION TO
SURVEILLED TRUMP ADVISOR CARTER
PAGE, WHOM YOU WILL HEAR FROM
THEM JUST A MOMENT.
THE PROBLEM WAS THE 2016 PAGE
FISA WARRANT WAS OBTAINED IN
PART USING FRAUDULENT
INFORMATION FROM THAT INFAMOUS
STEELE DOSSIER PAID FOR BY THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
RESET YOUR BRAIN FOR A MOMENT.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
IN THE MIDDLE OF A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION, WHEN A MAN WHO IS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT IS BOWING
TO DRAIN THE SWAMP, THERE COULD
HAVE BEEN A PLOT HATCHED AT THE
SENIOR LEVELS OF OUR GOVERNMENT
TO ENTRAP SECONDARY FIGURES IN
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN TO ULTIMATELY
GET TO DONALD TRUMP HIMSELF.
THEN THOSE FIGURES WERE TARGETED
AND SURVEILLED, AGAIN, EVEN
POSSIBLY TRUMP HIMSELF.
WHILE OF COURSE DEMOCRATS
LAUGHED, LAUGHED ALL OF THIS OFF
AS CONSPIRATORS.
>> THIS CLAIM, THAT THERE IS A
POLITICAL SPY EMBEDDED IN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN IS NONSENSE AND
YOU HEAR IT IN THE SAME TERMS
THAT TRUMP OFTEN SPEAKS, WHICH
IS PEOPLE ARE SAYING OR I'M
HEARING OR WE ARE BEING TOLD,
THAT'S ANOTHER WAY OF SAYING
THIS IS PATENTLY UNTRUE, BUT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SPREAD IT ANYWAY
AND IT IS SINGLE HE DESTRUCTIVE
OF OUR INSTITUTIONS, BUT THEN,
THAT'S THE POINT.
>> Laura: NO.
THE POINT IS DAY BY DAY WE LEARN
MORE INFORMATION THAT SEEMS TO
INDICATE THAT THE GOVERNMENT MAY
HAVE USED ITS PROSECUTORIAL AND
INVESTIGATIVE POWERS FOR A
POLITICAL END.
TO DO WHAT?
WELL, TO STOP CANDIDATE TRUMP,
AND WHEN THAT FAILED, TO DERAIL
HIS PRESIDENCY.
THIS IS THE DEEP STATE IN
ACTION.
I THINK IT'S REALLY UNWISE TO
DISMISS OUT OF HAND THE NOTION
THAT THE FBI COULD HAVE FOUND IT
WITHIN ITSELF TO SPY ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THEY NEVER WOULD HAVE DONE THAT.
WHILE AS THE FEDERALIST DAVID
REMINDS US, JOHN BRENNAN SPIED
ON THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH AND
LIED ABOUT IT TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
JAMES CLAPPER SPIED ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THROUGH A
DOMESTIC SURVEILLANCE PROGRAM
AND LIED ABOUT IT TO CONGRESS.
AND ALTHOUGH THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION NEVER TWEETED ANY
NASTY ATTACKS ON JOURNALISTS, IT
DID SPY ON AND PROSECUTE THEM.
IT'S COMPLETELY PLAUSIBLE THAT
THOSE IN THE UPPER ECHELON OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT SOUGHT TRUMP AS
A THREAT, THEN USED WOBBLY
EVIDENCE AS THE PRETEXT TO
INVESTIGATE HIS CAMPAIGN.
A GREAT PIECE, BY THE WAY.
FOR MORE THAN A YEAR NOW THE
PRESIDENT AND THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE LED BY DEVIN NUNES HAS
SOUGHT THE INITIAL UNREDACTED
DOCUMENTS THAT SPARKED THIS
COLLUSION BROKE.
WELL TODAY, THE FBI DIRECTOR AND
THE DEPUTY AG HAVE AGREED TO
GIVE CONGRESSIONAL MEMBERS
ACCESS TO HIGHLY CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS ABOUT THE RUSSIA
PROBE.
NOW THEY WANT TO SEE THE
INFORMATION CONCERNING THE FBI
INFORMANT WHO REPORTEDLY COZIED
UP TO AT LEAST THREE TRUMP
ASSOCIATES.
WHAT DO YOU CALL THIS GUY, A
SPY, AND INFORMANT OR JUST A
MOLE?
WHO CARES?
THAT'S JUST SEMANTICS.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, THE FBI
SENT THIS INFORMANT OUT TO MAKE
CONTACT WITH CARTER PAGE, GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS AND SAM CLOVIS.
THIS INFORMANT REPORTEDLY HAD A
SITDOWN WITH CARTER PAGE IN
EARLY JULY OF 2016.
WELL, THAT'S INTERESTING,
BECAUSE THAT UNDERMINES FORMER
FBI DIRECTOR JIM COMEY'S
CONTENTION THAT THE FBI DIDN'T
BEGIN ITS INVESTIGATION UNTIL
LATE JULY.
INCIDENTALLY, BETWEEN 2012 ALL
THE WAY UP TO 2018, NOW,
ACCORDING TO PUBLIC RECORDS,
THIS SAME INFORMANT RECEIVED
MORE THAN A MILLION DOLLARS.
WHAT KIND OF GENERAL FOREIGN
POLICY RESEARCH.
AND HE CONDUCTED THIS ALL
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE.
THAT'S ANOTHER INTERESTING
POINT.
THAT'S ALL VERY FISHY.
COME ON.
MANY QUESTIONS REMAIN ABOUT THIS
AND THEY ARE UNANSWERED.
TODAY FOLLOWING THAT WHITE HOUSE
MEETING, THE PRESIDENT SAID HE
HAS BEEN ABLE TO GET THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO AUTHORIZE ANOTHER
INSPECTOR GENERAL PROBE INTO
THESE SPY ALLEGATIONS.
THE PROBLEM WITH REFERRING THIS
INVESTIGATION TO THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL, AS GOOD OF A
GUY AS HE IS, HE HAS NO
PROSECUTORIAL OR OFFICIAL
DOES FIND RANK ABUSE BY OBAMA
OFFICIALS OR PERHAPS, WHO KNOWS,
EVEN OBAMA HIMSELF, IF HE KNEW
ABOUT IT, THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
WILL ONLY BE ABLE TO REFER THAT
INFORMATION TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
WHAT GOOD DOES THAT END UP
DOING?
THE PRESIDENT AND ALL OF US DO
HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW THE NAMES
OF ANY AND ALL AMERICANS WHO
WERE SURVEILLED AS PART OF THIS
ANTI-TRUMP HIT SQUAD OVER AT THE
DOJ.
AND WHEN WE FINALLY GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF ALL OF THIS WE SHOULD
HAVE THE NAMES OF ANY OFFICIALS
CURRENT OR FORMER WHO WERE PART
OF WHAT I BELIEVE WAS AN OBSCENE
ABUSE OF POWER.
THEY SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE,
ALL OF THEM, TO THE FULLEST
EXTENT OF THE LAW.
AND OF COURSE THE $64,000
QUESTION IS WHO ELSE IN THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION OTHER THAN
JIM COMEY, THE PEOPLE OF OTHER
HAVE ARTIE BEEN IDENTIFIED,
SIGNED OFF ON THIS, APPROVED OF
THIS?
HOW MUCH DID ATTORNEY GENERAL
LORETTA LYNCH KNOW ABOUT
CROSS FIRE HURRICANE?
AND WHILE THERE IS HISTORICAL
DISTANCE BETWEEN THE WHITE HOUSE
AND THE DOJ ON ONGOING CASES,
KIND OF INDEPENDENT, YOU THINK
ABOUT IT, IT KIND OF IS
UNFATHOMABLE THAT JIM COMEY AND
COMPANY WOULD CONDUCT AN
OPERATION LIKE THIS ONE WITHOUT
AT LEAST INFORMING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
OF COURSE THAN BARACK OBAMA.
AS LONG AS THESE QUESTIONS HANG
OUT THERE, I REALLY BELIEVE THAT
AMERICANS, MORE AND MORE OF THEM
ARE GOING TO THINK THAT OUR
GOVERNMENT TRIED AND MAYBE IS
STILL TRYING TO PULL OFF A